Bravo con weekend this is your first
Bravo con I like your haircut oh thank
you
a lot of uh suspicion rumors are coming
out about OC like what your marriage is
in trouble oh wait hold on and look
who's right here look who's carrying my
bag he's my [ __ ] I think that might say
everything this is my job this is my new
job
what did you make when you see those
come out that there's trouble in
Paradise there's a breakup coming right
you know you know success breeds
contempt and we did not get to this age
and this level of success without having
been stolen from blackmail threatened
you know all those things having
disloyal people in our lives we've also
had unbelievable amazing fun great times
and amazing people in our lives it's a
balance you have to not listen to those
things but you know we do have
life-changing things happening this
season well I saw some news from Heather
al-musa that you have purchased a
penthouse in L.A so what does that mean
for your future in OC by the way isn't
that so cute it's the reality TV overlap
is wild what's so funny is so so Terry
new tarek from the gym and we were at a
birthday party of our friendly Milani
and Heather and Tark were there and we
were talking and I was like yeah we're
gonna start looking for places in L.A
whatever and Heather's like I'll show
you and we said okay great and the four
of us became fast friends so much fun we
started looking at apartments and I
thought really we were just gonna see
where we wanted to be which area and we
found
that place and we fell in love with this
apartment and we had to have it and it
took us four and a half months to
negotiate it but we got it we got but
what does that mean for Chateau de bro
and your life in OC well
let's put it this way we have two kids
gone
Katarina's uh two years away from
leaving also and then only one left at
home
I think that as a New Yorker
transplanted to La dragged down to
Orange County I'm migrating home okay
okay so let's just see what happens
there Bryce has what's unfolded while
you're filming the season of OC made you
think about maybe I do just want to be
in LA full time well I mean you know
garcelle and I have been friends for a
long time Ren and I've known you you
want to pick up a diamond
well I do enjoy diamonds let's let's be
clear
um
we'll see where the wind takes us
because the other the other like rumor
that's come out is that you stopped
filming that you can't be around the
women since Tamara's return okay well
let me wait hey Gina
am I filming
am I filming yeah
I just wanted cooperation also they love
each other yeah by the way you guys look
so beautiful and they always PDA I just
want to see that they can't keep their
hands off whether there's cameras on
them
by the way she never stopped filming not
one day I know because they were not
happy but if they want me to stop for
like a week and let me have a little
vacation that would be okay well how do
you feel about Tamara coming back she
made a bold statement at watch it
happens live last night and she came to
save the show how do you what's it been
like to be reunited with her on screen
you know because you and I have talked
about this but you know that I always
think that Tamara's like my housewife
maker like a vampire when they bite you
you love them forever she was the one
that introduced me and I will love her
forever and we bonded the first day I
ever met her over being mothers and
that's very important to me and very
special
um I was happy when I heard she was
coming back we haven't had the easiest
Road you're gonna have to watch the
whole thing to see what happened happens
but as far as what she said last night
and I think I responded you know the
whole is greater than the sum of its
parts that the way these shows Thrive is
by everyone being amazing and and that's
it's an ensemble show
[Music]